we also have folks sending us in things
that are inappropriate for children
they're the inappropriate toys I don't
know if you realize this week or not how
much power we have on this show last
week we talked about two things
during the inappropriate toy segment and
both of them have been stricken from the
planet really yes that's gonna sway we
have that's the kind of investigative
journalism we're doing that's right we
talked about this little kid show a
cartoon called Maya the bee oh my god
this I saw this all over the news this
week and it wasn't as seen in them in
this little cartoon there was some
graffiti inside a hollowed-out log that
they fly by and this is a you can see it
right there it's a big big dick that was
drawn inside a hollow log and not even a
bee dick no like a human size has a big
dick and great a dick right there and so
parents freaked out and now Netflix has
pulled that episode from its catalog you
can't see that anymore because people
say the dick is inappropriate lame right
I love the apology that the studio that
created the cartoon released an
absolutely inappropriate image has been
discovered in a four-second flyby scene
in one of our episodes that's like a
half-assed apology they're like it's for
seconds what the [ __ ] really
yeah and then we also showed this photo
last week of a roller skating rink in
Tucson Arizona
they had a mural of Superman holding up
a water fountain and whenever the kids
would use the water found it would look
like they're sucking Superman off I come
from a planet far from here and
sometimes I come right here this week
last week we talked about this this week
they released this picture they've
repainted it showing him just carrying
it not with his [ __ ] out far more
appropriate but not nearly as amusing
that's what I'm saying so anyway anyway
here's this week's actual inappropriate
toys the first one comes from Rob he was
doing some miniature golfing with his
kids he's in the tri-city area there
Washington State and he thought this was
inappropriate I could see the point this
hole looks
that's the puffy vulva hole apparently
and you got a hole-in-one by getting a
hole in Hut in one there somebody who is
using their sucker pump in her one John
brine from Texarkana Texas sent this one
in it goes this would probably qualify
for inappropriate snacks I think he's
got a point the big box of boogers tangy
gummy boogers that look and feel real I
would imagine kids would find that fun
if they have a special helmet they wear
to school maybe my mom would have given
me those to be like leave your real ones
alone eat the fake ones you didn't eat
your boogers when your kids [ __ ] yeah
really they they were salty we're the
stores a lot of pretzels is just my
brother and sister when I was young like
they told me that boogers were just dead
brain cells so if you ate them you've
got smarter but the more you know but
I'll be honest with you like [ __ ] the
brains I was like they're salty not you
know [ __ ] different strokes and [ __ ]
and Gemma Lauren Stinson from st. Helens
England sent in this toy it's a game
actually kids are supposed to play it is
gassy the cow yeah will she Moo or will
she poo is the point of the game if you
don't quite understand how it works
here's a a commercial for gassy the
Kalba game
just choose your boots take a spin we'll
be number one the game can't see the cow
will she if she if the idea of the game
is to poo why they call her gassy
because sometimes you lift her tail up
and she just farts on you and then
sometimes you look to telephone your
boots hey that sounds like a fun game
well they split the difference call her
shorty the cow yeah it's an excellent
point
that looks fun if I was a kid I would
have liked to play with yes while you're
eating your boogers you could play - see
the pound blowing Superman from a water
fountain every week it's just more I
learned for about you it's just
disturbed
[Music]
you